that's right before Omar was coming on
the wire Johnny Depp of Peter DeLuise
were rocking the 21 Jump Street yeah
real cops alright not really real cops
but is what it is alright
intro 21 Jump Street right so 21 Jump
Street is based off the old TV show
starring Johnny Dada in which cops are
undercover in high school and all that
good stuff
in reality the movie 21 Jump Street is a
movie called 21 Jump Street really
doesn't have much to do with the old TV
show at all old TV show you know kind of
this hip young cop drama but you know
not drama but drama
like they watch with cops and high
school and no no chicks and swimsuits
but I do like how the movie uses that as
its strengths I mean it's a couple of
undercover cops infiltrating high school
no way that was going to be a drama so
they made it a comedy and as a comedy
they can even make fun of the fact that
it is what it is like when their
captain's giving them their assignment
he's like alright we're going to rehash
an old 80s program that we used to have
I guess the guys upstairs they just
can't think of anything news it's just
rehash old crap thinking people aren't
going to notice it made me laugh it was
pretty much going yeah we know what the
movie is so just laugh with us I so as
for the characters in 21 Jump Street
Channing Tatum and skinny Jonah Hill
they worked well together at first I was
like there's no way these two were going
to be friends and at first I really
didn't buy the fact that they became
friends but I just couldn't deny anymore
that they'd worked well together I mean
they contrast each other perfectly in a
movie like this it really worked and I
thought the humor of the fact that
Channing Tatum was the popular one in
high school Jonah Hill was not now in
high school things change course like
you know it's kind of hip to be nerdy
and Channing Tatum's people you know the
Xbox fans it's not as cool as it used to
be it even makes fun of the fact that
it's a cop movie like those just shoot
things that are flammable they don't
blow up and just like I thought that was
gonna blow up me me to this that just
didn't blow up made me laugh it was good
stuff and actually give this movie
credit that a lot of movies can't even
get Tony Hill likes this girl in the
movie and she's in high school but I
think she's 18 I think but the point is
she's the kind of girl that Jonah Hill's
character might just be able to get if
he had confidence I like that I like the
fact that the movies like we're not
gonna set him up with Miss February but
you know here you go it's a buddy cop
comedy and it's a buddy cop comedy that
made me laugh like quite a few times
actually I didn't think I'd laugh that
much in this movie also I've seen buddy
cop comedy before I've seen cop comedies
before I've seen cop-out not jaded me
for
life but 21 Jump Street is actually a
surprisingly good time in the end I will
say 21 Jump Street is a good time no
alcohol required if you are a hardcore
21 Jump Street fan that wants 21 Jump
Street on the big screen you won't like
the movie because it's not like that at
all they go their own direction in 21
Jump Street but they do it really well
if you want a funny cop movie for 21
Jump Street it's good a good cop comedy
that you like that'll be the question
what is it what's your favorite comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more